PLANET THAN ANY OTHER AMERICAN.
665 DAYS SPANNING THREE SPACE
STATIONS AND THE SPACE STATION
MISSIONS.
THE SECOND ROUND OF THE U.S.
OPEN GOLF CHAMPIONSHIP UNDERWAY
RIGHT NOW BEHIND ME.
YOU CAN SEE ALL OF THE ACTION
THIS WEEKEND ON THE FOX
BROADCAST NETWORK JOINING ME NOW
TO TALK ABOUT GOLF IN THE FUTURE
OF GOLF IS THE UNITED STATES
GOLF ASSOCIATION CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER MIKE DAVIS.
MIKE, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST.
THIS IS THE TROPHY?
>> THIS HAS THE TROPHY THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND SINCE 1895.
>> THAT'S FANTASTIC.
TO HEAR THE CHEERS COMING FROM
THE GOLF COURSE, EVERYONE IS
TRYING TO MAKE THE CUT RIGHT
NOW.
THIS HAS BEEN AN INTERESTING TWO
DAYS.
THIS IS A TOUGH PLACE.
>> IT IS ONE OF THE FIVE
FOUNDING CLUBS OF THE USGA, AND
IT TRULY IS A GREAT TEST OF GOLF
BUT IT WAS THE TALE OF REALLY
TWO DAYS.
YESTERDAY SOME OF THE HIGHEST
WINDS WE'VE EVER HAD AT
U.S. OPEN AND PLAYERS WERE JUST
HANGING ON.
YET TODAY, REALLY GOOD SCORING
FOR THE CONDITIONS.
VERY LIGHT WIND AND SOME SOFT
CONDITIONS AND THEY CAN GO LOW
WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
>> SO DID YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAD
TO SET IT UP TOUGHER BECAUSE
LAST YEAR WAS 16 AND UNDER?
YOU DIDN'T GET TO 16 OTHER THIS
YEAR?
>> IN SO MANY CASES,
MOTHER NATURE HAS A BIG SEAT AT
THE TABLE.
LAST YEAR SHE WAS VERY CALM TO
THE PLAYERS BUT SHE'S DOING A
FEW DIFFERENT THINGS THIS YEAR.
I THINK IN SOME WAYS YOU TRY TO
SET THIS GOLF COURSE UP, AND ANY
U.S. OPEN GOLF COURSE, SO YOU
ARE TESTING EVERY ELEMENT OF THE
PLAYER'S SKILL.
SO THE COURSE MANAGEMENT SKILLS,
EVEN THE ABILITY TO HANDLE THEIR
NERVES.
THIS IS A GREAT GOLF COURSE AND
A GREAT TEST OF GOLF.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT GOLF AS
A GAME AND WHERE IT'S GOING?
>> VERY HEALTHY GAME.
WE HAVE MORE JUNIOR GOLFERS IN
THE UNITED STATES AND OTHER.
SO IN A SENSE, AND THE GAME IS
GLOWING GLOBALLY.
IT'S A GAME OF A LIFETIME, IT'S
LIKE OTHER SPORTSWEAR PLAYERS OF
DIFFERING ABILITY CAN PLAY ON AN
EQUITABLE BASIS THROUGH THE
HANDICAP SYSTEM.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME GOLF HAS
ITS CHALLENGES.
ONE THING THAT GOLF CONTINUES TO
FOCUS ON IS HOW LONG IT TAKES TO
PLAY THE GAME.
THEN THERE ARE EVEN LONG-TERM
ISSUES, AND IT WILL BE A BIGGER
ISSUE IN THE DECADES TO COME.
IT IS ABOUT THE LONG-TERM HEALTH
AND ENJOYMENT OF THE GAME FOR
ALL THOSE WHO PLAY AT.
>> Bret: FOR SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T WATCH GOLF RELIGIOUSLY,
WHY SHOULD THEY WATCH THIS
WEEKEND?
>> THIS IS OUR NATION'S NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP.
IT'S THE OLDEST CHAMPIONSHIP IN
THIS COUNTRY, IT'S BEEN AROUND
SINCE 1895.
THIS WEEK IS TRULY UNIQUE IN THE
SENSE THAT, THIS IS THE ULTIMATE
TEST OF GOLF.
THIS IS UNLIKE OTHER WEEKS OF
THE YEAR WHERE WE ARE TESTING
EVERY ELEMENT OF THE SHOTMAKING
SKILLS.
FOR WELL OVER A CENTURY, THESE
GOLFERS KNOW THAT THE U.S. OPEN
TOUGH TEST TO GOLF, BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE WILL HAND OF
TROPHY OUT RIGHT HERE AND AT THE
JACK NICKLAUS GOLD MEDAL TO THE
LOW 72 HOLE SCORE.
I CAN PROMISE YOU, IT'S GOING TO
BE SOMEBODY THAT HAS WORKED
THEIR WAY AROUND THIS GOLF
COURSE AND DONE A GREAT JOB IN
TERMS OF THINKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH.
>> Bret: RIGHT NOW DUSTIN
JOHNSON IS LEADING.
HE HAS THESE GUYS THAT ARE
HITTING GARGANTUAN DISTANCES AND
IT'S CHANGING THE GAME?
>> THE GAME HAS EVOLVED.
IT HAS INNOVATED ITSELF.
WHEN WE PLAYED THIS CHAMPIONSHIP
WELL OVER 100 YEARS AGO IN 1896,
THE COURSE WAS ONLY 4400 YARDS.
NOW IT'S ABOUT 7400 YARDS.
COURSES HAVE HAD TO EXPAND OVER
THOSE PERIODS OF TIME, BUT
DISTANCE IS ONLY ONE ELEMENT OF
THE TEST.
YOU KNOW, IT'S YOUR ABILITY TO
BE ACCURATE WITH THE BALL,
DISTANCE CONTROL, YOUR ABILITY
TO WHEN YOU GET IN TROUBLE,
RECOVER.
AND ULTIMATELY, THINK YOU ARE
WAY AROUND THE GOLF COURSE.
>> BACK IN 1896, THAT WINTER GOT
A A FEW BLOCKS, BASICALLY $150.
AND IN FIRST PLACE THIS YEAR,
2.1.
SECOND PLACE GETS MORE THAN THE
2,000 FOR WINTER.
I'M >> I WONDER WHEN HE WAS
PLAYING, IF YOU LOOKED AT THAT
FROM AN INFLATIONARY -- SOMEHOW
I DON'T THINK $150 WOULD EQUAL